qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
un élastique et l'hostis sic je savais
pas que tu faisais de la moto j'étais
pas impossible
après le show sur moi que tu sais pas un
con te bonne crois moi tu as rien rater
[Musique]
génial celle là est électrique
ah oui je sais bien souvent un peu
nerveux mais je voulais tant petit jeu
va être super je vais être super et toi
aussi
on va être super au revoir
[Musique]
bon
il a l'air normal pourtant quand est-ce
que ça corse et quand hélène est parti
travailler je suppose qu'elle est au
courant non mais tu plaisantes comment
veux tu que je parle de ça c'est sa
toute première mission
je dois réussir afin qu'elle puisse
réussir afin que nous puissions réussir
ibor j'ai compris dix mois depuis quand
t'as pas dormi j'en sais rien j'ai
annoté et puis c'est un bébé je suis
capable de gérer singer jeunes donc tout
va très bien
tu contre parfaitement la situation et
surtout qui à chaque fois dit l'amf ou
qui a tort
si j'ai bien compris il est capable de
tan tan m dans l'autre dimension et lui
il est trop bizarre
paypal est tournée
l'été et démolition s'est échappé ou
absolument qu'on en fait
[Musique]
et c'est cet engin amandine avec
seulement deux chars de l'éloigner des
situations
[Musique]
merci jeune épouse est bien gentil
j'ai une question à vous poser quelle
est la principale cause de votre entrée
en disgrâce l'ignorance la perception
regardez aujourd'hui par exemple avec le
démolisseur situation compliquée vous
avez dû prendre des décisions difficiles
on m'en parlait pas je ne peux pas en
parler parce que je n'ai rien pu voir
personne n'a rien pu voir lorsque vous
combattez les méchants comme aujourd'hui
personne ne voit les combats mais ce qui
les a provoqués on ne voit que ce que
les politiciens pointe du doigt les gens
associent destruction et vous donc si
nous voulons changer la perception que
les gens ont des super héros
il faut que vous partagiez est votre
perception avec le monde entier et
comment fait-on cela avec des caméras en
incrustant de mini caméras comme celle
ci dans vos costumes incroyables ces
tout-petits et l'image est parfaite
merci c'est ma création
qu'à une tête de déterré robert je dors
presque plus je gâche la vie de ma fille
il n'arrête pas de changer les mains il
nous fallait des petites piles mais j'ai
acheté des grosses piles
résultat on n'a toujours pas de petites
piles j'ai mis un tee shirt rouge dans
une machine de blanc le l'agir sortie
aux roses il ya plus de vingt ans de
suivre enfin convenablement est un acte
plus qu'héroïque d'élever convenablement
je remercie le ciel tous les joueurs de
leur épargner cette tâche
pour
tu t'es laver les mains avec du savon
tu les as bien sécher je vous les donne
c'est moi sinon est ce qu il est prévu
qu'on en parle un jour croix du sujet
tabou évidemment quel sujet tabou
le nouveau travail de maman
il est temps grand temps de réparer nos
erreurs aidez nous à faire sortir de
l'ombre tous les supers nous devons
changer l'opinion des gens sur les
super-héros et pour cela élastique earl
est notre meilleur à toi meilleur que
moi
[Musique]
or marc cherry je m'occupe des enfants
pas problème c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire papa le prof dit qu'on veut
utiliser cette méthode je connais pas
cette méthode est pourquoi ils changent
les maths les maths c'est les maths mais
ma démarche est très bien je perds
c'est ça la petite de l'instance et
jacquet est très en forme c'est quoi ça
ok tiens tiens voici bloqués waouh
d'accord ça c'est plus bas c'est
complètement fou mon pour aider ma
famille je dois la quitte t il pour
faire régner la loi de la transgresser
pour nos enfants pour qu'ils puissent
avoir le choix
[Musique]
conditions imminent qu'est ce que ça
veut dire y'a le feu
aubin
l'une au teaser en terro ce programme
afin de vous délivrer un message en file
pour costume ça va chauffer j'arrive tu
me dépêche
[Musique]
ce unis
non pas
[Musique]
non
le plein cette année les battre
je venais d'être appelé
[Musique]
bah
plus à tes pouvoir bien jouer bébé
[Musique]
la police dans certaines têtes qualif
croyez qu'on devient pas vu sa mère trop
polis fort
or on se retrouve les super héros sont
hors la loi se faire la bagarre rival
la sentence est irrévocable veut pas
dire que tu quoi ouais j'ai entendu ça à
la télé ce millionnaire voudrait qu'on
le rencontre il ya un truc super héros
dans l'air il est temps pour les super
de reprendre du service
il nous faut hélas stickers au revoir
gérer
je m'occupe des enfants ne t'inquiète
pas non c'est pas comme ça que le propre
nous a dit de faire pourquoi il veut
qu'on fasse comme ça mais je sais pas
offert comme ça pourquoi ils veulent
changer les maths les pattes cinéma on
ne change pas les bacs partout dans nos
villes les dodgers endorment on s endort
le rêver il sombre lol sommeil je serais
pas arrivé ce qu'on n'ait pas pris le
relais il faut que je réussisse pour
qu'elle réussisse
les gars vous
c'est flippant mais je ne veux pas la
nourrir qu'avec
c'est tout un art il ya là et la manière